eines Jahres das für unsere Demokratie
von besonderer Bedeutung ist die
Europawahl sowie drei Landtagswahlen im
Osten werden die Menschen zur ohne rufen
und auf ihren Wahlzetteln stehen
Parteien die es erst seit heute oder
noch gar nicht gibt Parteigründung die
vor allen Dingen an den Rändern links
und rechts entstehen unsere Demokratie
steht an vielen Stellen unter Stress
multiple Krisen zunehmende Polarisierung
und Vertrauensschwund all das fordert
unsere Demokratie heraus verändert sich
mit der stati im Parteiensystem auch
unsere demokr e und Gesellschaft dieser
Frage begrüße ich Sie sehr herzlich bei
unter den
[Musik]
len und ich begrüße sehr herzlich
Professor Wolfgang Merkel
Politikwissenschaftler und ich begrüße
ebenfalls sehr herzlich Linda teberg von
der FDP Mitglied im Deutschen Bundestag
herzlich willkommen Herr Professor
Merkel heute hat sich eine bundesweite
neue Partei gegründet Bündnis Sara
Wagenknecht die zur Europawahl auf jeden
Fall auch antreten wird ist das eine
gute Nachricht für unsere pluralistische
und repräsentative Demokratie das lässt
sich glaube ich heute nicht definitiv
beantworten ob das gut oder schlecht ist
ich würde sagen es dihent sich der Bogen
aus von Bevölkerungs und
meinungsgruppen sie eine neue
Repräsentantin also nicht nur
Wagenknecht sondern eine Partei ob sie
allerdings die Dynamik dann so gestaltet
dass nach rechts außen die AFD sich
weiter radikalisiert weil sie ihren
Nimbus als Protestpartei behalten will
der wird ihr möglicherweise streitig
gemacht durch die neue
wagenknechtpartei und insofern könnte
man was Parteienforscher nnen eine
zentrifugale Bewegung eine Bewegung auf
die Pole hinaus und da werden die
Parteien in der Mitte nicht völlig
regungslos dabeiehen es könnte eine
Intensivierung des Populismus in unserer
Politik geben aber noch einmal Prognosen
sind dann besonders schwer wenn sie in
die Zukunft gerichtet sind richtig aber
grundsätzlich wenn man davon ausgeht ein
breiteres Angebot müsste doch eigentlich
auch besseres Marktangebot rein
theoretisch
gebe ich sofort zu aber auf die Frage
ist wie die Pole besetzt sind wenn sie
die 20er Jahre nicht dieses sondern des
vergangenen Jahrhunderts nehmen
da waren die Pole eben von
verfassungsfeindlichen
demokratiefeindlichen Parteien besetzt
das will ich den beiden nicht sofort
zuweisen ob sie das sind
bei der bei der wagenchtpartei würde ich
es nicht annehmen bei der AFD
diskutieren wir gerade darüber also wenn
wenn es System feindliche Parteien auf
dem Polen gibt ist es keine gute
Nachricht für die Demokratie fr
Teuteberg wir sprechen oft auch von
Politik Verdrossenheit wenn man aber
sieht wie viel Parteien sich gründen
oder auch wie sehr sich Menschen in der
Politik eigentlich jetzt auch auf mit
ihrem
Protest zu Wort melden dann müsste man
doch eigentlich fragen ist das jetzt
spricht das für
eine eine Auswirkung unserer Demokratie
oder eher gegen die Demokratie wenn sich
Menschen so engagieren das ist
zweischneidig also zunächst mal die
Gründung einer neuen Partei ist eine
Möglichkeit sich zu engagieren und ist
nicht per se negativ sie ist in der
Geschichte der Bundesrepublik sehr es es
immer sehr schwierig gewesen eine neue
Partei wirklich zu etablieren damit
Einfluss zu gewinnen es gibt wenige
Beispiele wo das gelungen ist aber ich
finde es ist ja zunächst mal Anzeichen
dafür dass es wenn man das als einen
Markt bezeichnen will von politischen
angeboten dass es da offen eine
Nachfrage gibt nach etwas was bisher
nicht genügend von anderen abgedeckt
wird und deshalb finde ich stellt sich
da die Rückfrage auch an andere schon
bestehende Parteien und das finde ich
müssen wir differenzieren gibt es nicht
auch ein Bedürfnis nach Position die
bisher nicht genug repräsentiert werden
eine
repräsentationslücke auch für Positionen
die durchaus verfassungsgemäß und
legitim sind die wir gerade nicht eben
einigen an den Polen und an den Rändern
überlassen wollen die aber nicht
hinreichend in den demokratischen
Parteien der Mitte abgebildet werden und
ich finde diese Frage sollten wir uns
stellen damit wir ähm klar es gibt das
Recht Parteien zu gründen und auch neue
neue Formationen zu bilden neue
politische Bewegung zu gründen
einerseits aber für die Stabilität ist
es ja trotzdem gut wenn das
Parteiensystem nicht zu zersplittert ist
wenn wir einige Akteure haben die
miteinander koalitionsfähig sind die für
einen lebendigen Wechsel von Regierung
sorgen aber von klar sozusagen
staatstragenden positiv die Demokratie
gestalten wollenden Parteien und da ich
finde die Migrationspolitik ist ein
Beispiel wo wir durchaus auch eine
repräsentationslücke haben für eine
Politik für die man eigentlich nicht an
die Pole gehen sollte und nicht müssen
sollte und da haben wir zum Teil
Probleme in der politischen Debatte und
das finde ich sollte die Folge sein auch
für die Parteien in der Mitte sich zu
fragen was können wir tun um zu un
unterscheiden es gibt Menschen die
können keine Zielgruppe sein für
demokratische Parteien die wirklich
fremden feindliche verfestigte
Auffassung haben den will man sich nicht
inhaltlich irgendwie annähern aber es
gibt auch viele Menschen die Parteien
die die wir sehr kritisch sehen wählen
oder in Umfragen angeben sie zu wählen
die durchaus nicht diese nicht solche
völkischen fremdenfeindlichen Ansichten
teilen aber die etwas vermissen und ich
glaube beides gründlich auseinander zu
halten das ist die Aufgabe wenn wir uns
in Deutschland die Partei Neugründungen
angucken die in in der Gegenwart
stattgefunden haben so ist das eben eher
an dem politischen Rändern wenn man nach
Europa schaut ist das gar nicht
unbedingt der Fall in Österreich die
Neos die sich gegründet haben oder auch
in Frankreich
die Renaissance Partei von von Emmanuel
macron wie erklären Sie sich
das ja find wir haben natürlich in
Deutschland schon die die AFD ist ja
zunächst im Zuge der Eurokrise gegründet
word sie hat aber ganz stark sie war
dann schon schon deutlich im im
Abschwung und hat im Zuge des Themas
Migration seit 2015 wieder einen
massiven Aufschwung erlebt und das hat
natürlich schon auch mit der Art wie wir
Debatten führen zu tun und ich finde da
ist eine wichtige Aufgabe mir ist das in
der Innenpolitik aufgefallen auch 20117
als ich neu in den Bundestag kam schon
dass wir dieser Partei z.B gar nicht
mehr Macht und Deutungshoheit geben
sollten als ihr zukommt qua
Wahlergebnis indem wir ständig sie zum
Bezugspunkt unserer Debatten machen also
ich kann ein innenpolitisches Thema sein
migrationsintegrationsfragen Fragen der
inneren Sicherheit die kann ich
ansprechen wenn ich sie für relevant
halte und auch mit meinen Liberalen
Lösungsvorschlägen unabhängig davon ob
auch eine selbsternannte Alternative
diese Themen auch anspricht und da dazu
auch eine Meinung hat oder die für
wichtig hält wir müssen in der Sache
argumentieren und wenn man auch aus aus
ganz anderen politischen Richtung z.B
aus einer liberalen oder konservativen
oder sozialdemokratischen diese Themen
eigentlich auch wichtig finden muss und
dafür Lösungsvorschläge machen dann
sollte man sich von einer anderen
politischen Kraft dieses Thema nicht zum
Tabu erklären lassen sondern nach
eigenem Kompass diese Themen ansprechen
weil sonst gibt man ja einer einer
Partei die man vorgibt bekämpfen zu
wollen die Deutungshoheit über unsere
Debatten und deshalb müssen wir uns
davon unabhängiger machen Herr Professor
was sind denn die Motive für die
Neugründung sind das die sogenannten
repräsentationslücken die Frau teutebar
ja auch ausgemacht hat und hat sich die
AFD wirklich aus der Mitte
herausgegründet nein das war eine
verschlafene professorenpartei vor allen
Dingen von Juristen und
Ökonomen die sich in erster Linie gegen
den Euro verbünden wollten und geglaubt
haben das genügt für das politische
Überleben und die Partei hat sich
radikalisiert und es gab ein kardinalen
Punkt und ich würde sagen ein
politikfehler unter der Regierung Merkel
dass sie die Flüchtlings und
Migrationswelle nicht in den Griff
bekommen hat noch mal ich sage deshalb
nichts es hätte abgergelt werden müssen
aber sie hat so getan es als wäre es
kein Fehler und hat gesagt das ist das
Land in dem ich leben wollte nicht in
einem Land wo wir uns einmauern also das
war der erste große
radikalisierungsschub und es war das
Thema dass die AFD gefunden hat und
tatsächlich eins das in gewisser Weise
nicht hinreichend für das
Meinungsspektrum in der Bevölkerung
durch die etablierten Parteien abgedeckt
war und warum in Deutschland Frau kze
warum in Deutschland sich Parteien vor
allen Dingen an den Rändern Gründen das
kann man fast mit einer simplen
politischen Mechanik beschreiben die
Mitte ist in Deutschland überbesetzt und
sie ist überbesetzt von relativ stabilen
Parteien nimmt man manchmal die FDP aus
die sozusagen an der 5% Grenze
herumtt aber es sind gut organisierte
Parteien auch im europäischen Vergleich
besetzen die Mitte weil sie aus der
Wahlforschung und von ihren
Meinungsforschungsinstituten wissen in
der Regel werden Wahlen in der Mitte
gewonnen weil es da mit Abstand die
meisten Wähler gibt aber dann öffnet man
auf der linken und der rechten einen
politischen Raum der verweist und
findet keine Repräsentant und das ist
die Chance für die neuen Parteien da
würde ich gerne noch mal nachfragen Herr
Professor Merkel wenn sie sagen dass wir
dass die Mitte eher überbesetzt ist wir
gleichzeitig aber unglaublich viele
Proteste auf den Straßen erleben und
ganz offensichtlich viel
Protestpotenzial da ist von
unterschiedlichsten Gruppen ich sag mal
von den klimaaktivisten letzte
Generation bis hin zu den Bauern die
diese Woche auf den Straßen
sind bereitet ihn diese Breite und die
Intensität der Straßenproteste Sorge
dass das System der repräsentativen
Demokratie dann doch irgendwo an seine
Grenzen stößt also die Heterogenität
dann zur großen Herausforderung für die
Demokratie wird die Proteste
ähm veranlassen mich gegenwärtig nicht
äh sofort äh von von demokratieprobleme
zu sprechen sie drücken aber etwas aus
sie drücken der Unzufriedenheit mit der
Politik im Allgemeinen und mit der
Regierungspolitik im Besonderen aus da
gibt es nichts wegzud deuteln aber
Protest und Demonstrationen und Streik
sind so etwas wie die auch die
dynamische Essenz für eine politische
und gesellschaftliche Weiterentwicklung
und insofern ist das auch ein Zeichen
von Lebendigkeit einer Demokratie aber
was wir gegenwärtig erleben sind vor
allen Dingen die Proteste von kleineren
strategisch gut platzierten Gruppen die
von daher mit geringer Repräsentanz
geringer Mitgliedzahlen
doch wichtige Bereiche unser
Gesellschaft und Wirtschaft lahmlegen
können und wir sehen ein Aufblühen diese
wie wir das nennen partik
Interessen teilinteressen und die zeigen
an dass es so etwas wie eine Erosion
eines Gemeinschafts eines
Zugehörigkeitsgefühls in unser
Gesellschaft gibt und da ist eine
Polarisierung im Gange die nicht völlig
unproblematisch für die Demokratie ist
vorsichtig formuliert frberg ist dieser
Wut und diesen Protest den wir da sehen
von teilweise
partikular wie Professor Merkel es sagte
ist das ein neues Phänomen in
Deutschland in der jetzigen Dichte und
und auch dass es so viel Aufmerksamkeit
bekommt schon aber Proteste gab es
natürlich auch früher schon und die
Brockdorf Entscheidung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts sie ist ja
auch entstanden weil es früher schon
Proteste
gab trotzdem finde ich schon dass es in
letzter Zeit noch mal Intensität
zugenommen hat und dass wir dass es
schon auch an die an grundsätzliche
Fragen geht nämlich älich an die Frage
das eigenerseits Protest und vor allem
sind Demonstrationen ja eine besondere
Form der Meinungs Äußerung besondere
Ausprägung der Meinungsfreiheit auch als
Versammlungsfreiheit in unserem
Grundgesetz und das ist gut und richtig
aber es dient natürlich tatsächlich der
Kommunikation der Einbringung einer
Meinung auch gerne sichtbar und spürbar
in den Diskurs es soll natürlich
eigentlich nicht dazu dienen durch sage
ich mal einen
anhaltenden Druck eine Art Nötigung
zu erzwingen dass Entscheidungen
getroffen werden das noch mal ein
Unterschied also einen Anliegen hörbar
sichtbar zu machen durch eine
Demonstration ist das eine aber dann so
eine Art ständigen Handlungsdruck oder
auch eine Art zermirbungs drruck zu
erzeugen ist noch mal eine andere ob
beabsichtigt oder als Nebenfolge aber
das ist ja das was sowohl im Zuge auch
der klimablockaden zum Teil mit die
Sorgen gemacht hat dass es auch eine Art
zusätzlicher Stress ist für die
Gesellschaft neben anderen Themen all
den Krisen über die wir diskutieren den
Fragen zunächst der Pandemie dann auch
jetzt der der Frage von Inflation Kosten
bei Energie und anderem das immer dann
diese Frage und das macht mir schon
Sorge dass Menschen den Eindruck haben
dass im Alltag jetzt Dinge auch nicht
funktionieren dass sie eben nicht zur
Arbeit kommen zusätzlichen Stress haben
nicht zur Arbeit nicht zur Schule dass
das sozusagen stimmungsmäßig einfach
noch mal eins drauf gibt und und und
eine ein vielleicht sonst sogar
bestehende ja Akzeptanz Geduld damit
dass man auch mal komplexe Themen nicht
sofort lösen kann dadurch zusätzlich auf
die Probe gestellt und
ja im Zweifel auch möglicherweise
beendet wird dass man da den Eindruck
hat im Alltag funktioniert so viel nicht
mehr und da ist mehr als Sand im
Getriebe und ich glaube das ist das
worum es im Moment auch sehr stark geht
bei unterschiedlichen Einschätzungen zu
Protesten und wenn wir ein ein eine
Vorkommnisse denken da finde ich schon
bemerkenswert
ich finde auch Gewalt Einschüchterung
gegen Personen gegen auch Politiker ist
inakzeptabel da gibt's aber auch eine
unterschiedliche Wahrnehmung wann man
das inakzeptabel findet wenn ich etwa an
die titip Demonstration vor einigen
Jahren denke da gab es auch Galgen als
Symbol an denen dann
Regierungsmitglieder damals
praktisch bildlich aufgehangen wurden
und da hat das weniger Empörung
öffentlich ausgelöst also ich finde es
für die glaubwürdig it in der Demokratie
auch sehr wichtig dass wir tatsächlich
bestimmte Spielregeln und und auch
Standards die wir haben wie man sich
verhält und wie man sich nicht verhält
dass wir die auch unabhängig davon ob
uns das Anliegen sympathisch ist oder ob
es das eigene politische Lager ist
konsequent vertreten sollten und dafür
haben doch einige manchmal eine gewisse
Doppelmoral wenn wir das Beispiel titip
jetzt mal aufgreifen wo ja auch schon
Dinge wie Frau Teuteberg sagte gezeigt
wurden die eigentlich so nicht
akzeptabel sind ähm und wir uns jetzt
sehr viel stärker darüber erregen was
teilweise gezeigt wird und auch passiert
an Gewalt ähm würden Sie sagen es liegt
vor allen Dingen an der Häufung der
unterschiedlichen Proteste die wir haben
und ähm an an der Häufung der Äußerung
der Partikularinteressen wie sie es
gesagt haben und die Konsequenzen die
daraus entstehen dass man nicht zur
Schule kann dass man nicht zur Arbeit
kann dass die Leute sich darüber ärgern
zunächst mal zu der Frage äh der Gewalt
wenn ich mich zurückerinnere in der
Bundesrepublik gab es ganz andere
Situation wo Proteste viel
gewaltförmiger vorgetragen worden sind
Brockdorf und sonstige Kernkraft
Auseinandersetzung auch die 68er
Demonstrationen waren sozusagen
gewaltförmige oder in den 50er Jahren
die Proteste gegen die wiedergewaffnung
also wir haben das und wir sollten heute
nicht so reden als wä es das finis
germanie oder Untergang des Abendlandes
das ist nicht der Fall was es aber
problematisch macht ist zum einen wenn
es gegen Personen geht also jetzt bei
harberg die Sache noch problematischer
wenn fackelzüge vor den Wohnungen also
von der
Intimsphäre der Politikerinnen und
Politiker auftauchen das finde ich sehr
bedrohlich
aber
das eigentlich problematische ist dass
diese Proteste was ausdrücken die
drücken Unsicherheit und
unzufriedenusheit aus und wenn ich mir
die Probleme der dieser 20er Jahre
ansehe da haben wir die Klimakrise wir
haben Krieg wir haben Migration wir
haben sogar
haushaltsproblematiken und außerhalb des
Haus der haushaltsfrage sind das alles
Krisen die kann die Regierung gar nicht
lösen die kann s nicht im
nationalstaatlichen Rahmen lösen und
schon gar nicht in der Schnelligkeit wie
gegenwärtig die Bürger
ungetu
aufscheint also wir werden diese
Verbindung zu den Protestformen
intensiviert vermutlich bekommen die
Regierung und die politischen Eliten
müssen nur eins besser zeigen meine ich
sie müssen zeigen dass sie die Probleme
ernsthaft effizient und fair
bearbeiten und dann kann es durchaus
Zustimmung geben und sie muss
organisieren was man die
eine eine politische Ökonomie der
demokratischen Geduld unter den Bürgern
nennen kann dann wird sie auch
mitgenommen aber das auch eine Ermahnung
dass Politik nicht bürokratisch von oben
wie das Gebäude Energiegesetz
fabriziert werden darf würden Sie sagen
dieser straßenprotest den wir hier jetzt
auch erleben könnte gefährlich für
unsere Gesellschaft sein und wenn wir
noch mal auf die parteig Gründungen
schauen die jetzt kommen würden Sie
sagen dass die Protestler damit auch
wieder zurück in das repräsentative
System geführt
werden in Krisenzeiten und Zeiten von
Unsicherheit gibt es so etwas wie einen
präferenzwandel
Einstellungswandel unter Bürgerinnen und
Bürger sie schauen dort viel deutlicher
auf die
politikergebnisse da geht es nicht mehr
so sehr um die Demokratisierung der
Demokratie wie können wir die
Partizipation erhöhen die Bürger wollen
das was Helmut Kohl mal in der ihm
eigenen Sprache genannt hat wichtig ist
was hinten herauskommt und diese
Fokussierung auf politikergebnisse die
müssen ernster genommen werden und man
muss davon nicht ab darf davon nicht
ablenken und sagen hier haben wir eine
und die haben wir eine problematische
Partei wie die AFD die müssen wir
observieren die müssen wir
möglicherweise verbi en nein sollte man
nicht so schnell tun wir sind eine
liberale Demokratie sollten nicht
illiberale Instrumente einsetzen es muss
eine Besinnung auf eine effiziente und
faire politische Entscheidungsstruktur
wachsen inwiefern deuten denn diese
neuen Parteigründungen die wir hier
erleben auch auf einen Versagen der
bisherigen Parteien hin denn
offensichtlich gibt's ja eine ganze
Reihe Menschen die sich nicht mehr er
fühlen von den bisherigen Parteien und
dem den Repräsentanten des Staates also
ich denke darauf deutet es auch hin also
es gibt definitiv Grund dazu sich das zu
Fragen wobei ich auch sagen will ich
find's ich finde beides ist richtig es
gibt große Fehler auch die gemacht
wurden weshalb es diese Entwicklung gibt
aber nicht nur wenn Herr Professor
Merkel gerade anspricht eine Art
Ökonomie der Geduld in der Demokratie
dann finde ich das auch sehr wichtig
find es auch wichtig dass man nicht
falsche Erwartungen weckt und dass man
auch sagt was man von Bürgern übrigens
auch erwartet in einer Demokratie aber
ich will bewusst das Beispiel aufgreifen
was sie Ansprachen nämlich das Gebäude
Energiegesetz auch heizungsgesetz
genannt
da finde ich hatten wir auch zum Teil
eine absurde Debatte denn
der Entwurf der aus dem Haus von her
habbeck kam der war alles andere als
beratungsreif um es mal so zu sagen auch
als Abgeordnete wir bekommen ja dann den
Entwurf in den Bundestag den das
Kabinett beschlossen hat der war nicht
so wie er hätte sein müssen um den in
dem Zeit Plan zu beraten und ich gehöre
zu einigen Abgeordneten in meiner
Fraktion die sehr viele Fragen
formuliert haben und da fand ich auch
den Diskurs in unserem Land etwas
seltsam wenn Abgeordnete sich gründlich
Gedanken machen bei so einem Gesetz was
Menschen und Unternehmen sehr betrifft
und hohe Kosten nach sich ziehen wird
die kann man politisch richtig finden
aber man muss verantwortliche abwegungen
treffen was sind da die richtigen
Lösungen und wenn man bei so einem
Gesetzentwurf der z.B die kommunale
wärmeplanung ja noch nicht mal enthielt
so richtig äh im Gesetzentwurf dass man
da als Abgeordnete sagt wir bringen mal
zu Papier was wir da für Gedanken und
Fragen und Bedenken haben und die wollen
wir jetzt gründlich klären und
beantwortet haben bevor wir so einem
Gesetz zustimmen dann finde ich ist das
nach einigermaßen unvoreingenommener
Betrachtung eher was positives dass man
die Aufgabe ernst nimmt als Abgeordneter
bis dieses Urteil aus Karlsruhe dann kam
der Beschluss äh wurde das aber in der
Bundesrepublik hier eher so diskutiert
als sei das irgendwie ein Ehrenrühriges
Rebellentum und nicht eigentlich die
Ernsthaftigkeit der Auseinandersetzung
mit einem Gesetz was tief eingreift in
die Lebenswirklichkeit vieler Menschen
vieler Unternehmen und insofern glaube
ich haben wir da einfach Anlass darüber
auch mal zu sprechen wie werden die
Debatten in unserer repuik über manches
geführt ist da eigentlich genug
Verständnis dafür da dass einschneidende
Entscheidungen manchmal auch Zeit
brauchen denn wenn das Gesetz erstmal
verabschiedet ist dann ist nämlich
regelmäßig nicht später das Urteil über
so ein Gesetz ach wie toll dass die das
so schnell beschlossen haben sondern
dann wird gefragt funktioniert das in
der Praxis welche Auswirkung hat das auf
mich aber die Debatte vor der
Sommerpause ist von vielen so geführt
worden als sei es etwas Ehrenrühriges
wenn man nicht sofort die Hand dafür
hebt dass das vor der Sommerpause
beschlossen werden muss und deshalb
finde ich wir tun damit der Demokratie
kein Gefallen wenn wir auch da oft
Debatten sehr moralisiert führen auch da
lief die Debatte so als müsse wer für
das wichtige Anliegen des Klimaschutzes
ist unkritisch für diesen Gesetzentwurf
sein und das sind zwei verschiedene
Dinge und ich glaube das sollten wir
öfter auseinanderhalten denn was mir
wirklich sehr wichtig ist als Liberale
ist auch diese Systemkonkurrenz in der
wir stehen mit Russland mit China jetzt
weltweit und da ist genau diese
Handlungsfähigkeit der der Demokratie
Probleme lösen zu können
durchsetzungsfähig zu sein die ist ganz
enorm wichtig und da fällt mir einfach
auf dass auch für würde ich jetzt mal
sagen Bürgerinnen und Bürger die
durchaus besonden sind sind die sich
Gedanken machen über die Themen über die
Krisen ist doch ein riesiger Widerspruch
ist wenn wir in Deutschland z.B
einerseits sagen wir seien nicht in der
Lage z.B unsere Grenzen zu kontrollieren
oder Migration irgendwie rechtsstaatlich
zu begrenzen zu steuern aber wir wollen
den Anspruch erheben z.B mit deutscher
Politik das Weltklima zu retten dann
gibt es da einen riesigen Widerspruch
zwischen Fatalismus auf der einen Seite
wo einige die möglichst keine Begrenzung
von M wollen so tun als könne der Staat
gar nichts tun statt einfach mal
politisch zu begründen dass sie nichts
tun wollen das ja eine legitime Meinung
aber die muss man dann auch ehrlich
vertreten und andererseits ein
machtbarkeitswahn und eine
unrealistische Politik vorzuschlagen wo
gar nicht mehr gefragt wird was kann
denn funktionieren welche sozialen
wirtschaftlichen Folgen hat das was ist
unser Anteil in der Welt und was könnte
unser sinnvoller Beitrag sein und diese
Dinge glaube ich da brauchen wir
sachlichere Debatten das ist etwas was
auch auch Menschen auffällt die sich
Gedanken über diese Krisen machen
sachlichere Debatten Herr Professor
Merkel auf der einen Seite wenn wir
jetzt mal ganz konkret Richtung Osten
schauen wo dieses Jahr drei
Landtagswahlen stattfinden und da werden
die Menschen dann darüber entscheiden
wenn sie in der Wahlurne sind wie sie
die Debattenkultur fanden oder wie sie
eben die eine oder andere Partei auch
fanden ist es ein Zufall dass jetzt
diese neuen Parteigründungen die sich da
gebildet haben vor allen Dingen im Osten
auf große Zustimmung stoßen das wissen
wir noch nicht bei der AFD wissen wir es
ob die
wagenknchpartei einen
ähnlichen ein ähnliches Echo erzielen
kann
das wissen wir nicht ist eher nicht so
zu erwarten und Herr Marsen kommt dann
wahrscheinlich auch Herr Maren ist eine
irlichternde Figur das ist Herr Marsen
wird keine Partei gründen können die
sich
festsetzt dafür ist er zu weit im AFD
Lager also hat keinen genuinen eigenen
Raum von Charisma kann man nur sagen die
klassische Absenz von jeglichem Charisma
er wird nicht Marktplätze füllen er kann
im Hintergrund sozusagen Rechte teraden
Spinnen also von Maßen würde ich mich
nicht einschüchtern lassen was aber
abläuft in diesem Jahr ist schon ein
etwas
unglücklicher Kalender von politisch
Wahlen wir haben erst äh die Wahlen zum
Europaparlament und dann haben wir die
drei Landtagswahlen in Ostdeutschland
alle vier Wahlen sind das was wir äh was
wir nennen indirekte Wahlen es sind
Wahlen zweiter Ordnung das heißt man
wählt nicht die Abgeordneten für das
Europäische Parlament die werden so und
so nicht gekannt das muss man einfach
sagen von der Bevölkerung der
Durchschnitt der Bevölkerung wird keine
fünf Abgeordneten aus den deutschen
Parteien aufzählen können aber sie
machen folgendes ist ein Denkzettel an
die
nationalstaatliche Regierung es wird ein
Denkzettel gegenüber Berlin und der
optimale
protesttenkzettel oder gar der
schlimmste denkbare Zettel wird die AFD
sein davon wird die AFD profitieren und
da kann man nur hoffen dass vielleicht
schon die wagenknechtpartei äh dort
antritt und der AFD doch etwas Wasser
abgräbt und ähnliches haben wir auch bei
den Landtagswahlen auch das sind second
order Wahlen zweiter Ordnung auch da
gibt es insbesondere in der Mitte der
Legislatur das Bedürfnis eine Botschaft
an die Bundesregierung zu senden und äh
das wird man wiederum mit der größten
Protest Partei machen also es käme
darauf an dass diese
wagenknechtgründung diese neue Partei
das Monopol auf radikalen Protest der
AFD aus den Händen nimmt und das macht
gegenwerärtig die AFD doch sehr stark
weil es keine die Partei gibt die diesen
Protest so radikal ausdrückt die Linke
ist es nicht mehr die Linke hat sich
gewissermaßen in das System einqu
wahrscheinlich zu sehr für viele
unzufriedene Teile der Bevölkerung in
Ostdeutschland muss man da konstatieren
dass die
Mitteparteien es nicht dauerhaft
schaffen die Menschen im Osten
tatsächlich zu
überzeugen also dass dass es da eine
Aufgabe gibt eine Herausforderung ist
ganz klar wennleich ich da auch wichtig
finde weil das ist schon bisschen Teil
des Problems wie blicken wir auf den
Osten der
Republik bisher und trotzdem wird schon
so immer über Ostdeutschland berichtet
ist es ja schon so dass immer noch eine
Mehrheit andere Parteien wählt trotzdem
wird sehr stark Ostdeutschland immer
unter diesem Thema gesehen wie sind die
Ergebnisse der AFD oder eben der der
Linkspartei bisher ja sind mit Abstand
stärkste Kraft laut Umfragen in ja aber
auch als es ich will damit ja trotzdem
aber auch als es noch nicht so war wurde
schon sehr stark so berichtet also das
heißt die Frage nehmen wir auch mal
Ostdeutschland in seinen jedenfalls mehr
Meinungsvielfalt war ist noch mal wäre
eine gesondertes Sendung Thema wert denn
es gibt natürlich schon auch in
Ostdeutschland viele die anders denken
aber wo man immer nur so einen gewissen
Exoten zublick hat auf auf
Ostdeutschland und nicht auch über die
vielen die sich für die Demokratie
engagieren in Ostdeutschland und die es
da umso schwieriger haben berichtet
aber wichtig finde ich daran auch
ich sehe das auch mit so Sorge wie
Professor Merkel was die Bedeutung
dieser Wahlen angeht ich sehe allerdings
auch dass in unseren politischen
Debatten diese die zum Teil berechtigte
Sorge um die Demokratie ich könnte auch
sagen die Systemfrage manchmal wiederum
instrumentalisiert wird wenn wir bei
diesem Thema zu repräsentationslücken
zurückkommen es gibt Menschen die haben
z.B ein legitimes Bedürfnis nach einer
würd jetzt sagen restriktiven aber
rechtsstaatlichen Migrationspolitik die
in der Polarisierung unserer Debatten
nicht reichend abgebildet wird und wenn
wir diese Debatten über die notwendige
Abgrenzung gegenüber der selbsternanten
Alternative haben dann ist die zwar
einerseits notwendig diese Abgrenzung
das steht außer Frage sie wird aber auch
gern instrumentalisiert um von
konservativen und liberalen Parteien
eigentlich faktisch einen Linksruck zu
verlangen um nicht sozusagen bei jeder
Kleinigkeit den Vorwurf zu bekommen weil
einem Antrag auch die AFD zustimmt oder
es Schnittmengen gibt was aber in der
Natur der Sache liegt bei einer bei
jeglicher Politik die dann sozusagen
nicht nicht links ist von ihrem Anspruch
her dass man dann auch schnell mit so
Vorwürfen kommt wie jetzt Frau esken
Herrn März vorzuwerfen er sei
brandgefährlich dafür muss man seine
Wortwahl nicht glücklich finden aber die
Antwort einer konservativen Partei kann
ja nicht sein sich möglichst links
auszurichten um diesen Vorwurf nicht zu
bekommen das heißt auch da muss man Maß
und Mitte waren und zwischen dem
notwendigen gemeinsamen Kampf von demok
warten für die Demokratie als System
unterscheiden und das nicht
parteipolitisch instrumentalisieren und
inflationär mit diesem Vorwurf umzugehen
jede Politik die einem nicht gefällt die
einem nicht links oder vermeintlich
progressiv genug ist mit so einem
Vorwurf zu versehen weil das ist dann
für die Demokratie auch nicht gut aber
das mag schon wenn ich ich das sagen
darf das mag schon stimmen wenn sie
sagen wir sollten auch auf die System
tragen denn die demokratischen Parteien
auch in Ostdeutschland äh schauen und
darüber reden und nicht nur eine sich
selbsterfüllende Prophezeiung nur über
das Anwachsen der AFD die Gefahr äh in
Ostdeutschland sehe ich aber dass mit
der AFD mittlerweile ein
vetoakteur in der Politik entstanden ist
nicht dass die jetzt sofort in
irgendwelche
Regierungskoalitionen reinspringen
können da glaube ich noch an die
Brandmauer sondern die können die
anderen Parteien zwingen quasi zu all
Parteien
antid Koalitionen und das wiederum
fördert den Mythos und den Nimbus der
Protestpartei
die könnten sich nur oder schließen sich
nur zusammen weil sie die AFD verhindern
wollen das ist das alte Lied wir werden
ausgeschlossen das ist undemokratisch
dass die AFD so gerne sinkt und es
könnte gewissermaßen strukturell
erzwungen werden wenn man die AFD
richtigerweise aus der Regierung
raushält wenn man wenn man sich das
anschaut sie haben von Wahlen zweiter
Ordnung gesprochen bei den
Landtagswahlen die jetzt anstehen gerade
im Osten
wenn man sich anschaut womit die AFD da
auch Wahlkampf macht nämlich mit den
Themen Migration Transformation das sind
ja genau die Themen die man im Land
nicht unbedingt angehen kann weil sie
viel globaler angelegt werden müssen das
erzeugt aber bei den Menschen Angst das
Thema Migration oder auch transf tion
wird damit zunehm Politik gemacht na
klar das sind die Fragen und das wissen
wir die die Bevölkerung bedrängen und
ich sag's mal so insbesondere die
sozioökonomisch gesprochen die untere
Hälfte der Bevölkerung die oberen 10 und
20% sind so und so fein heraus die sind
von diesen Problemen irgendwo tangiert
aber nicht substanziell in ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Existenz und was wir
erleben werden und und das wird sich
verschärfen
ist es gibt gegenwärtig Transformation
die gleichzeitig anlaufen müssen nehmen
wir die Klimafrage wir müssen möglichst
schnell Technologien entwickeln die
wirkungsvoll die
Erderwärmung zurückfahren und eindämmen
wir brauchen Märkte die gewissermaßen
eine schöpferische Zerstörung der alten
Strukturen erlauben dass sich diese
Technologien so schnell wie möglich
festsetzen hier ist Tempo gefragt auf
der anderen Seite haben wir eine Politik
die demokratisch sein muss und
Demokratie braucht Zeit die Demokratie
muss sich die Zeit nehmen und sie darf
sich nicht drängen lassen wie das damals
auch 2008 in der Finanzkrise gewesen ist
wo die Kanzlerin das Parlament genötigt
hatte so schnell wie möglich zu
entscheiden und diese Ungleichzeitigkeit
dieser politischen Transformation und
der wirtschaftlichen
Transformationen wird deshalb
problematisch weil am Anfang einer
wirkungsvollen Politik so etwas wie ein
Tal der Tränen beginnt es wird Kosten
geben es werden Lasten zu Schuldern sein
und die werden wiederum die
unterere bevölkerungshälfte sehr viel
stärker als die oberen treffen und
dieses Tal der Tränen ist das
problematische wo
der Politik es gelingen muss so etwas
wie Zustimmung in der Bevölkerung zu
erhalten aber das ist ein Problem jeder
demokratischen Politik die spätestens
nach 4er Jahren Legislatur erste Mal neu
bestimmt wird und deshalb halten sich
Parteien auch zurück bei so
langfristigen Politiken war am Anfang
die Kosten anfahen und die Rendite wird
möglicherweise nach den Wahlen an die
Opposition ausgezahlt Frau teberg wenn
wir von von den Angst der Menschen auch
sprechen vor Transformation vor
Klimakrise W das andere Migration und so
weiter in dem Zusammenhang spielt ja die
Rhetorik und wie Politik damit umgeht
eine unglaublich große Rolle
gleichzeitig ist das aber auch auf das
Handwerk der Populisten die damit mit
einschreiten inwiefern gibt es eine
negative Angleichung der Rhetorik durch
die Partei in der Mitte an diese diese
angstpopulistische Rhetorik
mhm ich glaube die die gibt es in Teilen
aber es gibt genauso bei manchen die
Tendenz auch dann wenn Dinge sehr
sachlich vorgetragen werden sie entweder
dann zu überhören oder auch genauso
abzutun also Migration war ein Beispiel
was ich genannt habe wo man das schon
sehr gut an der Debatte nachweisen kann
also bis vor einigen Monaten galt es
noch als als äh kaum ähm kaum vertretbar
äh obwohl es auch da schon richtig war
überhaupt von sowas wie pullfaktoren als
m relevanten Argument bei seinen
Lösungsvorschlägen zu sprechen also für
mich war das als ich Migration in der
letzten Legislaturperiode als Sprecherin
bearbeitet habe schon eine wichtige
Frage wenn man über solche Dinge wie
Spurwechsel oder nicht nachdenkt auch
pullfaktoren in seine Argumentation
einzubeziehen die gibt es nämlich aber
das war ist etwas was bis vor kurzem bis
dann auch alle Ministerpräsidenten
gesagt haben wir sind überlastet wir
müssen etwas tun um Migration zu
begrenzen war das eher nicht akzeptiert
z.B in der Debatte und das sind da ist
eine Tatsache nur weil sie von manchen
als abgelehnt wird ist ist das nicht
automatisch Populismus umgekehrt gibt es
übrigens manchmal Populismus auch aus
von Akteuren demokratischer Parteien um
schnellen Beifall zu finden ich sag ihn
jetzt mal ein ganz aktuelles Beispiel
was mich geärgert hat der
Ministerpräsident meines Landes Herr
Wutke hat zu diesem jetzt im Hinblick
auf diesen Haushaltskompromiss und die
Proteste davon gesprochen ähm dass ähm
das Streit der Ampel Demokratie
zersetzend sei und das
Ministerpräsidenten ja näher an den
Menschen sein als Abgeordnete um diesen
Haushaltskompromiss da zu kritisieren
ähm ich komme da mal zurück auf ihre
Bemerkung von der ged Ökonomie der
Geduld auch in der Demokratie dieser
Kompromiss kurz vor Weihnachten ist ja
eher dieser öffentlichen Erwartung da
muss unbedingt vor Weihnachten noch mal
eine Entscheidung her geschuldet und da
waren Abgeordnete gar nicht drei
beteiligt sondern drei spitzenpersonen
der an der Koalition beteiligten
Parteien haben sich da zusammengesetzt
um das jetzt später noch mal teilweise
zu revidieren das hat aber mehr damit zu
tun a mit diesem Erwartungsdruck dass
alles schnell gehen muss anstatt
vielleicht auch zu sagen politische
Führung ist auch mal zu sagen wenn wir
jetzt so einen Konsolidierungsbedarf
haben den wir vorher nicht eingeplant
haben dann ist eine sachliche
Entscheidung darüber wo wir diese Mittel
einsparen kann jetzt auch mal ein paar
Wochen brauchen und das ist auch in
Ordnung das jetzt im Januar ordentlich
zu entscheiden wir werden es aber
gründlich tun wäre auch eine Möglichkeit
gewesen aber Tatsache ist es ist keine
Alternative wie es her W ge forderte
dass da auch noch die
Ministerpräsidenten eingebunden werden
müssen Haushaltsgesetzgeber ist schon
noch der Bundestag der ist vor
Weihnachten jetzt damit nicht befasst
worden das wird jetzt im Januar alles
gemacht diese Woche finden die Anhörung
statt und Ende Januar soll der Haushalt
beschlossen werden ich will nur sagen
antiparlamentarische Ressentiments zu
bedienen ist leider kein exklusive äh
exklusives Merkmal nur von Extremisten
oder denen die wir landläufig als
Populisten bezeichnet und ich finde auch
hier müssen wir aufpassen dass wir die
Stärken auch der parlamentarischen
Demokratie durchaus z.B
Interessenausgleich Dinge gründlich zu
durchdenken auch selbst zeigen und
positiv ins Schaufenster stellen um es
mal so zu sagen aber natürlich nicht als
Ausrede oder mit etwas ewig dauert aber
sachlich begründet zu sagen
tiefgreifende Entscheidungen sei es
jetzt der Bundeshaushalt ih noch mal neu
aufzustellen oder so etwas wie das
Gebäude Energiegesetz die können schon
mal ein paar Wochen der abwegung
benötigen und das muss man dann auch mit
breitem Kreuz vertreten und sagen das
ist der Zeitraum in dem wir jetzt zu
einer Entscheidung kommen und da werden
wir die Dinge die zu bedenken sind auch
bedenken und abwägen aber nicht
sozusagen so tun als sei alles so eine
moralische Frage von Gut und Böse von
denen die guten Willens sind und denen
die irgendwie weit abgehoben sind das
ist noch auch eine Art
Politisierung das zu so einer gut böse
Frage zu machen ich glaube das hilft uns
nicht aber am Anfang waren wir noch bei
der Frage warum verschärft sich die
Sprache in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung warum nimmt sie
populistische Kulturen an und wir
sollten einen Punkt nicht vergessen den
ich für den stärksten Treiber dieses
Populismus und einer unversöhnlichen
Sprache finde und das sind die sozialen
Netzwerke wer sich auf Twitter tummelt
weiß das da wird mit offenen Visier
nicht nur schlimme Beleidigungen sondern
auch Gewalt angetroht und die die
Grenzen zwischen der Existenz der
virtuellen Existenz in den sozialen
Netzwerken und in der tatsächlichen
Realität sind poröse geworden und das
schwabt über das lässt auch
Protestaktion schnell mobilisieren auch
mit allen
Radikalen kabular und das treibt die
Polarisierung in der Gesellschaft sehr
sehr stark wir sind quasi am Ende der
Sendung Herr Professor Merkel wir haben
über die Herausforderung der Demokratie
gesprochen zu Beginn des Jahres die
vielen Partikularinteressen die vielen
Proteste die wir haben die multiblen
Krisen die wir haben ähm wie
optimistisch sind Sie wenn es um die
Stabilität unserer Demokratie geht wenn
wir über Krise wenn wir über
Schwierigkeiten über Probleme der
Demokratie reden ist das nur die Hälfte
die andere Hälfte ist tatsächlich das
was man Resilienz mittlerweile nennt
Widerstandsfähigkeit demokratische
Potenziale in der Gesellschaft und ich
will mir es nicht leicht machen und
sagen die Zivilgesellschaft soll es
wieder mal richten das würde er gern
wenn man kein Argument hat setzt man
immer auf die Zivilgesellschaft aber wir
sind mittlerweile eine Demokratie die 75
Jahre gut gelebt hat als demokrate
sich weiterentwickelt hat niemand wollte
wirklich in die 60er und 70er Jahre
zurück schon gar nicht schwule Frauen
oder jene die
in den in diesen Jahrzehnten noch
richtig diskriminiert worden sind und da
haben wir Potenzial auch wenn wir über
die Grenzen hinweg blicken wir sind
nicht Finnland und Dänemark aber wir
sind immer unter den besten 20 Ländern
dieser Welt wenn es und da reden wir
über 200 Länder wenn es um demokratische
Qualität geht wir haben einen
Herausforderer und wir haben
herausfordernde Probleme für die
Demokratie in den 20er Jahren aber ich
sehe nicht dass diese 20er Jahre zu 20er
Jahren wie im im 20 Jahrhundert werden
also insofern ist das ein positive
Einschätzung bitte um kurze Antwort auch
ihre einz wie widerstandsfähig ist
unsere Demokratie wie sehr können wir
uns da weiterentwickeln also ich finde
die Demokratie als System die bietet da
ganz viele Möglichkeiten aber es ist so
Geschichte verläuft weder zufällig noch
zwangsläufig deshalb kommt auch auf
jeden und jede von uns an wie wir in
diesem Jahr und auch drüber hinaus
agieren ob wir ja genau eben die die
bereit sind auch mal über die ganzen
Leistungen der Demokratie die wir immer
als selbstverständlich nehmen ähnlich
wie ich es bei der Marktwirtschaft sehe
W wo manche dann andere Träume haben
dass wir vieles nehmen wir für
selbstverständlich was funktioniert aber
ich finde wir müssen uns auch der
wirklich der Herausforderung stellen als
Politiker demokratischer Parteien die
Leistungsfähigkeit der Demokratie auch
im Sinne von einem durchsetzungsfähigen
problemlösungsfähigen Staat unter Beweis
zu stellen deshalb ist mir dieses Thema
so wichtig was ich ansprach nicht so ein
Fatalismus bei manchen Themen weil man
zu vielleicht zu bequem ist politisch zu
erklären warum man so entscheidet
sondern wirklich zu sagen was sind die
Staatsaufgaben und die müssen auch
erfüllt werden auch mal den Mut zu haben
was es auch nicht Aufgabe des Staates
und muss anders gelöst werden aber
wirklich zu zeigen da wo der Staat
gefragt ist da muss er auch Ergebnisse
zeigen herzlichen Dank für diese
angeregte Diskussion ihnen beiden und
ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen fürs
zuschauen das wäre unsere erste unter
den lindenendung in diesem Jahr morgen
um 22:15 Uhr sehen Sie an dieser Stelle
die phönixrunde und ich wünsche ihn noch
einen schönen Abend bei
[Musik]
Phönix
ه